need motivation watch a top ten with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
uplifting creative advice from Mark
Manson to give you the confidence
motivation and belief that you need okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
find good struggles problems are
basically the building block of
happiness and that is really
counterintuitive to most people because
most people think of happiness is like
no problems you know sitting on the
beach with a pina colada doing whatever
and but the truth is that we need we
need some sort of struggle in our life
and the point I try to make in the book
is that the key to living a good life
isn't getting rid of struggle it's
finding good struggles struggles that
invigorate you struggles that feel
important to you struggles that can
contribute to the people around you
because that's where meaning comes from
and ultimately meaning is you know what
we all need if people listening to this
like feel stuck in some way generally
when people feel stuck it's because
they're in a situation where they
believe that they don't have the power
to solve whatever is going on in their
life and the truth is that you always
have the power to a reacts to whatever's
going on in your life or be create the
meaning around whatever is happening in
your life so it's usually just a matter
of first changing perspective and then
be doing something the said about
solving it and again it's what gets
people stuck is that they just they want
to eliminate their problems it's not
about eliminating problems it's about
simply finding something more meaningful
more worthwhile rule number two create
what you love so this next book
everything is I started out I was like
alright you know I gotta I gotta keep
the train going you know and so I like
started trying to write stuff that you
know I thought subtle art readers we're
gonna really love and and yeah it just
it felt very empty it started to feel
like like a job
forced ya which I didn't become an offer
to have a job I became an author so you
know
I can do what I love and and I just kept
scrapping it I'm like no no this is this
isn't going well and eventually I'd just
get back to like okay I need the right
for myself first yeah
then once I have a book that I'm proud
of that I think is great then I can look
at it and say like okay like how can we
you know maybe change this or market
this so that it will sell a lot of
copies you know that's step two but step
one it always has to be in a creative
process it always has to be about
yourself first mm-hmm and otherwise it's
just it's not art anymore yeah it kills
the meaning rule number three try on new
values let's say I'm just really
superficial my value money more than
anything it like I've got like a fleet
of yachts and it's it's all I care about
you know and then something happens in
my life and I realize that that's pretty
superficial I should let grow up a bit
and you know value something else and
it's not as simple as just deciding like
we've all had that experience in our
lives where we wish we cared about
something that we don't or vice-versa we
wish we didn't care about something that
we do and you can't just stop and so the
process that I described in the book is
that essentially before you can commit
to a new value you kind of have to like
try them on like like it's like going to
a store and trying on a bunch of pairs
of clothes and the way you try on a new
value is you need to sit down and
visualize and you can even write it out
if you want but it's like let's say all
I care about is my fleet of boats and
and I want to try on a new value like
charity or something I have to sit down
and start asking myself what would it
mean for my life what would it mean for
me as a person if I didn't value those
boats anymore
and that's a very hard question it
really it messes us up because we
realize that a lot of our relationships
would probably fall apart a lot of our
business commitments would probably fall
apart a lot of our understanding of
ourselves would be shaken up or
questioned and it's a very difficult
thing to ask
and so you know most of the times when
you see visualization taught in the
self-help industry it's like they take a
guy who wants a fleet of boats and they
say visualize a fleet of boats now go
get it and it's like no no what you need
to do is take a guy who wants a fleet of
boats and say visualize not wanting a
fleet of boats what would that say about
you who would you be if that thing you
always desired was not your desire
anymore
rule number four be comfortable with the
adversity the truth is that indifference
is not it doesn't solve any of your life
problems indifference is actually just
another form of avoidance of life's
problems and so a healthy form of not
giving of like what what people aspire
to and they say like I just wish I
didn't give a about this is they wish
that they didn't give about whatever
adversity or or struggles that they need
to deal with to accomplish their goals
and they have a hard time doing that so
it's not giving us all about learning
how to just simply be comfortable with
the adversity also if you want to learn
from other successful writers check out
my 250 for writers wisdom series it's
free the link to join is in a
description below I've been reading a
lot of historical fiction and I've been
in the back of my mind you cannot go
around saying you want to be a writer
you can only go around saying I am a
writer it's not enough to know what you
want you have to to do what you want to
be what you want rule number five set
realistic goals I love this and that and
always the thing I don't know which
direction to go yeah and so they don't
go anywhere
it's like you got to pick that one thing
that is kind of the central value in
your life and then the second component
is that you need to feel that you're
capable of getting there so it's like if
I if I if I decided that the goal of my
life is to be you know the prime
minister of checklist of akhiya you know
it's that's not gonna happen
that's just unrealistic and so if you
have this vision that is just completely
detached from reality and you see this a
lot people will pick goals or dreams
that are just so out there
that it gives them an excuse and to not
do anything mmm
you know it's like oh well there's no
way I can make it anyway so I might as
well just sit around sit around the
Doritos or whatever plays out all day
exactly exactly exactly it's like I'm
not gonna sell 10 million books again so
I'll place all that you know like so
it's it's about finding a vision that
can kind of bring both of those things
together it's about being realistic
about who you are where you are and also
having a solid making a solid decision
about like what is better in the world
what is a worthwhile pursuit really rule
number six do what lights you up
emotionally you need to look for things
that light you up emotionally think
about what you want to do with your life
rationally and there's a time and place
for that but if the emotional components
not there if you're not passionate or
it's not even passion necessarily but
like excited or intrigued or filled up
by what what you want to pursue then at
some point you're gonna burn out
you're gonna lose interest as soon as
you stop getting the benefit of that
thing you're gonna wonder what the hell
you just spent the last three or four
years doing and a good way to do this a
good kind of litmus test for this is ask
yourself which activities drain you so
which activities like the more hours you
do them the more exhausted and burnt out
you feel and which activities light you
up which activities do you like forget
to stop doing and the funny thing about
finding passion or finding something
that lights you up is that they tend to
be things that seem so natural to us
that we don't even realize that we do
them I think a good exercise is to ask a
few people around you you know what what
do i do or what do I seem to love that
most people don't because other people
are often better at seeing it than you
are
rule number seven don't beat yourself up
one of the big points I wanted to get
across with the book is that it's it's
okay to feel bad like it we're all
you're gonna feel bad sometimes I don't
care how successful you are I don't care
how amazing your life is how great your
relationships are everybody's gonna feel
bad sometimes and a huge component of
living a healthy life is being good at
accepting that because when you stop
accepting that you know when you try to
deny your anger
or you get mad at yourself because
you're anxious or you feel bad because
you feel bad it creates this feedback
loop you know you start feeling guilty
and how guilty you feel all the time or
you start getting angry at the fact that
you're angry which makes you even more
angry and then you just start spiraling
out of control and the whole problem is
this judgment that negative emotions are
not acceptable you know if you feel
anxious you say it being anxious is part
of life like it's normal to be anxious
you're probably anxious for a good
reason if you're angry you might be
angry for a good reason it's these
negative emotions aren't necessarily
negative a lot of times they're very
helpful and and so it's just learning
how to care about something deeper than
the emotion itself rule number eight
always have a dream this is one of those
things people don't talk tell you about
success is that if you have this dream
for like your whole life and then you
accomplish that dream you don't have a
dream anymore and that's terrifying
because it's you wake up and you're like
oh crap what do I do with myself you
know it's like okay I got money and I
got like like a lot of fans but like I
had this dream like I don't I don't know
what to dream for anymore and and so I
went through this period for about six
months where I was just like really like
wow man well what's the point of all
this you know like what I worked so hard
for twelve years to get to this point
and what just to play Zelda all day like
is that is that it like I'm 33 you know
like is this really all it's gonna be
because you're driven how many articles
for your website hundreds yeah you know
I I started in in oh seven Wow online
and so yeah in it it took the way I
describe it is that it took time to find
new dreams new things to new visions for
like the future that I want for
yeah I eventually reached the point
where I was like you know I pitched a
bunch of book ideas to my publisher and
you know they're like oh it's on brand
and this is great you know it's gonna be
a good follow up or whatever and it just
nothing was working
and then I reached that point where I'm
like I got to go back to basics I gotta
write something it's true to myself you
know my formula through my whole career
has always been my writing is basically
just a very public form of therapy so
like whatever issues I'm going through I
write it out and I write it out in such
a way that you know hopefully other
people can get something out of it as
well that's for me for the podcast too I
you know all the people that I mean the
most help with yeah you know on
relationships for business or whatever
totally and so I went back to them like
all right I need let's start out by
writing about what I'm struggling with
and so that that's where the whole theme
of hope came in is it's like I didn't
know what the hope for anymore mmm and
that strangely enough that caused me to
be just as depressed as low points in my
life where I had no money and my
girlfriend left me and I also had
nothing to hope for and so I it made me
realize that you know what's going on in
the material world is totally you know
not the point it's a side effect what
matters is do we have that vision of
hope in our mind
do we see a possible future for us to
step into that will make our lives
better and as soon as you take away that
vision we don't know what to do with
ourselves and we we despair essentially
mm-hmm so that's the starting point of
the book is how how we need to
constantly be constructing these dreams
and these visions for ourselves and what
happens when they're taken away rule
number nine
find your lie so my background is a
little bit Buddhist and I subscribe to
the belief of no self essentially that
that our conception of who we are is
just kind of this arbitrary imagined
thing in our brain and so I think of our
relationship with ourselves as being a
basically functioning the same way as
like our relationship with another human
being so when something when you lose
a part of yourself so I spent pretty
much all my my early life wanting to be
a musician that was my ambition it was
my hobby my passion it's how I spent all
my time and I went to music school and I
just got this kicked out of me and I was
like oh this is not gonna work anymore
and the process of letting go of that
value was was very much similar to like
a breakup like it felt like losing a
girlfriend or losing a friendship like
this thing that gave all this meaning
and emotion to my life was now
unavailable to me and whenever you you
lose something like that
you go through the same emotional
process which is that a prop that
process of grieving or mourning because
the same way you know a breakup leaves
you grieving this beautiful thing in
your life that no longer exists when you
lose an important value or an important
part of yourself you also grieve this
beautiful thing that defined your life
and no longer defines it how do you help
people in that so that they don't
succumb to a trap I know you're the
example that you gave in in one of your
articles I thought was so hilarious
which is the being driven being
ambitious towards something without
taking a moment to reflect in the
morality of what you've decided to value
and you said take Hitler who's one of
the most driven people and this had this
tremendous impact but was a psychopath
yeah so walk us through like you you go
pretty into like how we can sort of
reason our way to really having a base
understanding of heard you talk about
Conte and like Natalie it's like a
really deep level yeah so how do we
begin to to get to a base level of like
okay now I'm gonna stack my belief
system my values on top of this base
sure just a little background on the
Hitler thing for our viewers you think
you need to clarify no I I wanted for so
long I've wanted I I had this idea with
a friend we got drunk and went
paintballing and and I
yeah where most my ideas come from and I
was talking to him I was like you know
it'd be amazing if you did like he did
like a Tim Ferriss style podcast with
like a fake Hitler and you're like so
eight off
what's your morning roots you know like
how do you rally the troops how do you
inspire millions of people and it would
just be this beautiful satire of kind of
like like focusing on that point of like
if so if you're not improving yourself
for the right reasons you could be
damaging yourself you know the the why
behind everything everything you try to
improve or everything that you're driven
towards is is more important than
actually you know how far you get so for
me it's it's I see a very direct
connection between self-improvement and
ethics I think if you if you dig deep
enough into these questions of what
growth means or what improvement means
you never believe in to what is better
period what is better or worse period
what makes a better life what makes
humanity better and so it's my goal has
always been I never want to be that guy
on stage who's like this is what you
should do this is how you do it here's
my five step method blah blah blah you
know I I want to be the guy who who
doesn't I don't want to give answers I
want to give better questions I want to
help people sort through these questions
in themselves because ultimately the
these questions around values are so
personal there's there's no way for me
to answer any individual without
inserting my values onto them and when
you do that you rob them of the ability
to choose what matters for themselves
choose their own meaning in their life
and rule number ten the last one before
very special bonus clip is question your
life write down your goals and then ask
yourself why do I want each of these
goals what would it mean in my life if I
accomplish these goals similarly you
know a common exercise is like write
down things you're grateful for ask
yourself why are you grateful for them
what would happen to your life if you
didn't have them
I mean that that's the crazy thing is
that a lot of a lot of times the things
were most grateful for are actually the
things that were all up about you know
it's like it's if you had asked me when
I was you know in one out like I had a
series of very dysfunctional
relationships I was happy as a pig in
the middle is you know I would be like
oh my girlfriend is the most most
beautiful thing and you know and it's
like no dude like you're I was a mess
and so we it's not just about
questioning you know the bad things in
our life you know like why did this
painful thing happen you need to
question the good things as well like
why why does this feel good is it does
it feel good for a good reason because
there are a lot of things that feel good
that are actually hurting you now I've
got a special bonus clip from mark on
how to find your creative process that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that is time for that three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to take an action
here we go question number one where do
you need to stop beating yourself up
number two what adversity do you need to
get comfortable with and number three
what's your next realistic goal his new
best-selling book is called the subtle
art of not giving a counterintuitive
approach to living a good life where he
talks about how the key to living a
better life isn't caring about more but
rather focusing on less
I had the idea for the title for years
and the way I work with my articles is I
don't I don't plan them I just kind of a
brainstorm a bunch of different ideas
and then when it comes time to write
something I just look at it and pick
whatever feels good so this title sat on
my little sheet for like two three years
and it's such a good title that was like
in I need to come up with something that
you know deserves the the it was like a
dreary Saturday and I just started
feeling very I was kind of down and when
I get down if you start feeling very
sarcastic and irreverent and just like
to write a bunch of bull
and so I was like I'm gonna sit down I'm
gonna write an article and it's gonna do
two things one it's going to be the most
offensive and vulgar thing anybody's
ever read and two it's going to give the
best life advice that anybody's ever
read and I'm gonna do it at the same
time and I want to create this like
mixture of emotion and and so yeah I sat
down banged it out and and I went crazy
it went I mean it was shared I think
over a million times
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Marie Forleo check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there start before you're ready if you
wait until you feel ready to do anything
meaningful you're going to be waiting
for the rest of your life